at the beginning of all of this at the
beginning of covid
you and i were hearing claims that you
know these vaccines are safe and
effective and it's like well well at the
beginning of code we weren't because we
didn't exist
okay well i could tell you one thing
right away you're lying when you say
it's safe because safe you know i can't
tell you that there's a harm but i can
tell you you don't know anything about
what this does to you five years 10
years 20 years down the road you
couldn't it hasn't existed long enough
and so you're telling me that it's safe
is you
either admitting that you don't
understand what you're saying or that
you're willing to mislead me but either
way i am now going to be super cautious
because i know that you're not telling
me the truth
now i want to point something out
we've got
various mantras that we use little
things that we say to flag certain kinds
of errors right like you know trade-offs
are a key thing for us because if you're
not talking about the trade-offs and
these things the chances are you're
involved in a sales pitch you're not
involved in a cost-benefit analysis yeah
the cost-benefit of the analysis
requires the trade-offs we also say
welcome to complex systems and by that
what we mean is
you are now dealing with a realm so
complex
that as soon as you tell me you know all
of the effects of the thing that you've
just proposed if the thing you've just
proposed is sufficiently novel you don't
know all the effects and the one thing
you can say to make me more comfortable
with you is we don't know all the
effects and if you don't say that then
the point is then the question is well
what did you miss and here i don't know
if you noticed this this this week
but i believe the 25th of february
a swedish paper
emerged
that actually upended a lot of the stuff
that um
some of our antagonists have crowed
about
very subtly and what it said
this is this is a single paper maybe
it's wrong it's a single paper that
demonstrated something in vitro that is
to say not in living creatures but in
tissues outside of living creatures what
it showed
was
that um
the
vaccines the mrna vaccines actually get
reverse transcribed into dna which is
then found in the nucleus
of liver cells
uh-oh is right now it isn't 100 clear
what that means the one thing that you
would love to know above all else which
they did not show in this paper was that
it gets that it does or does not get
uh
basically spliced into the genome right
right which is a crucial question right
but they did show interestingly
that the fact of this mrna getting
uh reverse transcribed into dna which is
the language of the genome
then up regulates
a appallingly named protein something
like line one i mean god biologists i
love biologists
but they suck at naming things and this
is a particularly
bad case of that
that
failure on their part but anyway it up
regulates
the very machinery that reverse
transcribes mrna so it's even
suggestive of a positive feedback
mechanism
now
[Music]
there are a million possibilities here
right it's likely that
this never makes it into the germline
right even if it does
get
cut spliced into the genome in the
nuclei of cells in some part of the body
that it never makes it to the germ line
and so it doesn't like an evolutionary
dead end but that doesn't help the
individual right but i mean i guess the
point is look
a
people have fought over the question and
those on the
the vaccine enthusiast side have crowed
endlessly about the fact that this is
not gene therapy because it does not
it does not touch the uh the nuclear
genome right and you know
i i've stayed out of that because yeah
it's not supposed to
but
so it's it's about um unintended
consequences
and complex systems
and specifically the hyper novelty about
which we go on so much in hunter
gatherer's guide and
with which we are all surrounded really
if you're interested in that
uh paper this the uh swedish paper on
the um
reverse transcription of the mrna
messages check out dr mobine saeed he's
one of the heroes of
the covid pandemic he's got an excellent
series on youtube in which he explores
uh medical questions in depth rather
like
like john campbell and and others
anyway check out his recent video on the
february 25th um
swedish paper on reverse transcription
uh we will put a link to that
um and i also will put a link to the
paper itself so you can look at it
but you know you've got a small number
of people who are committed to not doing
sales the sales thing has gone after us
right it has
it has gone after us because it cannot
tolerate an encounter
with um
frankly the scientific method
right and that i mean this is this is
the irony of the whole thing i'm
reminded
i'm reminded of the idiot ecologist and
sorry not all ecologists but this guy
was truly special
who said to me smugly
i used to think hypothesis was important
now i know better
now i know worse
[Music]
you